every once in a while social media
explodes with videos of people trying to
do some weird dangerous challenge like
the tide pod challenge or the corn cob
challenge well this week tick tock was
flooded with people doing the milk crate
challenge where people build a staircase
out of milk crates and then they try to
climb it doesn't sound too hard does it
well take a look
[Applause]
it's not funny
people are really hurting themselves
doing this
it's a dangerous trend that has to stop
yes i agree nobody should be doing it
would you do it no
of course not it's stupid i would never
me neither
but uh sometimes
sometimes
i hear the call of the milk crate
what
the milk crate
he calls to me
amber
yes
where is that coming from
it's coming from that milk crate
backstage
common climbing amber
but milk crate won't i bust my ass
not you amber
your ass is unbustable
my ass is unbustable
[Applause]
amber
i think you could do it that is exactly
how i feel
all the other people trying this
challenge are dummies but not you
not me
you can do it i can do it you cannot do
it you're gonna bust your ass
don't listen to him he is not your
friend
i am your friend
we're all your friends
you can do it
you
are the chosen one
i am the chosen one amber you are not
the chosen one
yesterday you threw your back out trying
to tie your shoe stay out of this tarik
maybe he's right
maybe you shouldn't climb us
yeah
if you're too
scared
hey i'm not too scared amber this is a
trick and you're falling for it you
can't fall for amber
amber
um
[Music]
how'd that go
mind your business
[Music]
you